I'll tell you how Denmark deliberately makes life as difficult as possible
for rejected asylum seekers and violates their human rights in Denmark
thousands of rejected asylum seekers go underground to avoid being deported
that means living off the radar and often surviving on the streets
but in 2017 the government passed laws explicitly targeting foreign visitors
on Denmark’s streets
they outlawed begging,
setting up camp in certain areas
and also homeless groups that create insecurity for the Danish public
in 2021 the UN urged Denmark to stop criminalizing poverty
and get rid of the begging law
Denmark has done neither
since 1997 motivation enhancement measures have been part of Danish law
they outlined that rejected asylum seekers should be kept in
isolated institutions with low living standards
to encourage them to leave the country for example
The Centre for Europe's anti torture committee called one of these places
immigration centre
not suitable for humans
and threatened to take Denmark to the
European Court of Human Rights because of it
why is Denmark doing this?
Denmark is obliged to process asylum cases according to international law
but at the same time
the government has stated that its goal is zero asylum seekers
so by making life as tough as possible for rejected asylum seekers
Denmark is doing three things
1) pushing people out of the country faster than they can legally be deported
2) violating their human rights
and 3) sending a message abroad that asylum seekers are not welcome in Denmark